The Joe Rogan Experience let me ask you
this one then what do you think about
all this the Pentagon saying that
there's crafts that are coming from
another world that's that's a new world
order what do you think that is though
uh getting people to believe in the fake
alien invasion
so what do you think those things are
these people keep saying uh it's
probably
um who knows uh the Nazis were scaring
their people with UFOs they made UFOs
like and they were like scaring people
it's like uh look at the Timeline the
times we're trying to develop some kind
of an actual Flying Saucer and they were
scaring their people and they were using
like look we're gonna save you look UFOs
that were scaring them there the
government's gonna save you from the
UFOs right so 1946 World War II is over
uh 1946-47 Operation Paperclip that's
when we took a bunch of Nazis and Russia
took a bunch of Nazis and so 1947
Roswell
right there that was Roswell was the
beginning of the UFO craze right after
Roswell all these comic books Mars
Attacks in the 50s all these shitty ass
space movies and alien movies
Star Trek came but Roswell kicked it off
that was the first one that kicked it
off so like wow that's 1947 that's right
when we brought in all the Nazis uh
who knows man maybe maybe them Nazis
were like dude you guys aren't scaring
your people with UFOs
you dumb [ __ ] just get on it
boom so that Roswell like they just uh
take some craft and then they get the
people that they interviewed probably
think it was real like uh it was a crap
it was an orchestrated crash just to
freak people out I think it seems like a
lot of money talk oh you covered up and
hide it when is anything too expensive
when is anything official for the
governor but the official answer was
never that it was a craft official
answer was that it's a [ __ ] weather
balloon and everybody believed that they
get people yeah they showed the record
but but uh people that believe in UFOs
like myself and you back in the day I no
longer I have a different view of UFOs
now but uh back then we didn't care that
they said like the fact that they said
that oh it's just weather balloons we
were like oh dude you guys are [ __ ]
and you're trying to cover up the real
[ __ ] so playing 3D chess exactly so
that's what I think it's drones I'm I'm
of the opinion drones and and you know
how those little red laser pointers you
know you [ __ ] with your cat with that
[ __ ] you go it's incredible speeds yeah
but there's some stuff there's some
stuff like the commander David forever
one is pretty important for sure they're
seeing stuff for sure they're seeing
stuff like I think I think Bob Lazar saw
some [ __ ] yeah I think they set him up
that's what I think I think he's telling
the truth but they set him up that's
what they do they take that's what
William Cooper said he was set up too he
worked for the Office of Naval
intelligence uh setting up meetings like
high level meetings and and they he said
he thinks that he was reading he was
setting up meetings and looking at
documents going oh [ __ ] they're going to
be discussing crash UFO [ __ ] and and
reverse uh engineering crash UFOs so at
first he believed it then eventually he
realized oh they set him up
um
he thinks they set up due to talk a lot
big mouths that are drunks that's what
he thinks he said they set them up and
they [ __ ] and that's what he brought
him up big mouths to the drunks because
they know they're gonna give out the
information and talk they want them to
talk so they let them get in there they
let him see it no don't go into that
room we'll be right back don't go in
that room we're gonna go and then they
go in they see like a like Philip Corso
remember that guy who from the Pentagon
back in the day when I was into all this
[ __ ] I was like look dude from the
Pentagon is saying it of course it's got
to be true dude a Navy pilot is saying
it of course they're the most credible
you're like but now looking back I'm
like dude now of course it's the dude in
the Pentagon Philip Corso said he wrote
a book the day after or something he
wrote a book about how he saw the bodies
in the confidence he saw the mind he
goes I was there I saw the bodies
I mean
so either he really saw alien bodies
like he walked in a room and they were
in a casket and it was open casket or
something like that either he really saw
that or or he did see it and they
weren't real or something and he was set
up imagine they set him up [ __ ] crazy
diseases that would come from an alien
body can you imagine they would just
have an alien body in a room and you
could do an autopsy on it with one of
those stupid masks on
yeah can you imagine just stop and think
of that because they think about like
the Europeans that came to North America
and killed 90 of the Native Americans
with smallpox imagine what the [ __ ]
aliens have imagine what [ __ ] that is in
there if they're a biological creature
they they probably exist like we do
we're filled with bacteria we're filled
like there's more
there's more E coli in your gut than
have ever been people ever
we're filled with this stuff imagine
what kind of crazy diseases
some alien body would have yeah that you
have no immunity to no and just ravages
the population everyone's dead and these
guys just have these little stupid masks
on they're cutting into this alien